what is another name for angle cpa so we
have c
we have p
and we have a so angle c p a is going to
be this angle right over here so what's
another name for it well i could start
off with a and i could call it angle a
p
c
so this is the same thing as angle a
p
c
now or is that any one of my choices
yeah that's this choice that's this
choice right over here if someone said
angle p that wouldn't give you a lot of
information that kind of says well you
know that's only giving me one point i
don't know maybe it's referring to that
angle that angle that angle that angle
so that's really not giving me enough
information to specify this angle right
over here
angle pac
would be an angle formed if you actually
had a line here if you had a line
between ac
angle pac would be this angle right over
here which is clearly a different angle
angle fpa
fpa
would be this angle right over here
which is also clearly a different angle
so the only choice that makes sense is
angle apc